hi I'm Erik Bosse and we have our first
look at the Joker movie starring Joaquin
Phoenix who doesn't need any clown
makeup or chemical burns to look like
he's gonna ruin your day already in this
preview we're getting some miscible
details pointing to the Killing Joke
graphic novel and we're getting the
sense of what kind of origin movie this
is gonna be and how it's gonna be
different from the other DC movies that
could be a good thing let's look at how
exactly this movie is gonna portray the
Joker's backstory based on the comics
but also another cinematic influences
the team is drawing from here is
everything you need to know about Joker
okay so along with some set photos and
some footage director Todd Phillips just
released this photo of Joaquin Phoenix
with the caption our third in this movie
The Joker's name is Arthur Fleck and
yeah Kevin Smith wanted out but that a
Fleck is a little similar to a flick
guys I think this trolling is really
getting to hello darkness my old friend
Fleck is a struggling comedian who lives
with his mother penny who's played by
Francis Conroy this whole comedian
backstory is similar to the Joker origin
that we saw in Alan Moore's The Killing
Joke which isn't definitively canon
since the Joker is not really a reliable
narrator but check out the wall behind
flag on it is painted the words
amusement mile that is an established
location in Gotham City in it's home to
an amusement park and in The Killing
Joke the Joker kidnaps Commissioner
Gordon and takes him to a rundown
amusement park now it looks like Gordon
wolves up here in this movie but we
could see some version of that storyline
adapted into this movies story instead
this movie's cast includes Robert De
Niro as a comedy talk show host reports
have said that Todd Phillips is taking
inspiration from Martin Scorsese's 1982
movie the king of comedy that movie De
Niro plays a mentally disturbed comedian
who kidnaps a late-night host and forces
him to let him do a set on a show he
ends up doing the set and the studio
audience loves his jokes about his
tragic childhood the movie is just a
really dark take on celebrity and
showbiz and this Joker movie looks like
it's going for the same tone it's also
set in the 80s which was a very
one-track cutthroat world for stand-up
comedians really the one sure path to
fame and fortune was to get booked to do
a set on The Tonight Show with Johnny
Carson and pray that you were funny
enough for Johnny to wave you over to
the couch so that America could get to
know you better
that's honestly how comics like Jerry
Seinfeld and Jim Carrey and Ellen
DeGeneres became stars but it was a ton
of pressure for comics to book this one
gig and hope it went well a lot of them
didn't so
ended up okay just did a lot of drugs
and now hosts podcasts whereas others we
never heard from again we're all we know
they're dressing up as clowns and
terrorizing cities actually that would
be pretty cool anyway we could be seeing
something similar to that story here
notice how in these images Arthur is
storming out of the offices of haha'
talent booking the comedian Marc Maron
will play a small part of this movie as
a booking agent for De Niro's Show who I
assume here is turning Arthur away this
could lead to a similar story to the
movie the king of comedy with De Niro
now as the late-night host and Phoenix
as the struggling comedian who snaps and
seeing this confrontation in the street
with this clown is interesting when
Arthur blows smoke in this guy's face
and it tosses his clown nose in the
street could almost imagine the moment
that inspires art reflect to take on a
clown as his moniker and by the way this
clown here is played by the character
actor Glenn flesh ler who's super
talented in his own right he's appeared
at Barry on HBO and in billions and he
played the terrifying yellow King on
true detective the bottom line is this
Joker movie will not be a true superhero
genre movie the way DC movies like
Justice League of Wonder Woman work or
even a DC antihero movie the way Suicide
Squad was this is gonna be more of a
standalone crime thriller it just uses a
lot of the proper nouns from the DC
Universe and it will be the first movie
to launch DC's non a DC EU movie label
DC dark or DC black names still TBD it's
for exactly these kind of movies that
aren't meant to be part of franchises or
interconnected cinematic universes
personally speaking I kind of like it
better that way for DC compared to
Marvel DC strength has always been its
standalone arcs and adaptations authors
taking over character names and giving
us their own unique take on the themes
that the characters represent and we've
seen this in the movies too there's a
lot to love about both Tim Burton's
Batman and Joker and Chris Nolan's
Batman and Joker and the fact that they
belong to their own unique cinematic
universes and never cross over it's kind
of what makes them great so I have high
hopes that this Joker movie can give us
another interesting take just look at
the cast of this movie it's amazing
along with the actors I just mentioned
there's also ZZ beats from Deadpool -
she's playing Sophie du monde who's a
hardened lower-class
single mother rumored to be a love
interest for Arthur and recently Brett
Cullen was cast as Thomas Wayne father
to Bruce Wayne remember Alec Baldwin was
briefly attached the
but he stepped down after a rumors swirl
that this version of Thomas Wayne would
resemble an 80s Donald Trump but now
Brett Collins playing the part you may
remember him from The Dark Knight Rises
as congressman Byron Gilly what are
there DC characters would you like to
see in this kind of standalone nandi CEO
movie we do have a Harley Quinn
birds-of-prey movie in the pipeline and
who knows what's going on with Matt
Reeves Batman movie but for me
personally I wouldn't mind a Dick
Grayson Nightwing movie that has nothing
to do with the rest of the DCE you know
post-credits scene teasing Legion of
Doom whatever comment down below with
your DC dream movie and follow me on
Twitter and Instagram at a boss and if
you're a fan of superhero stuff and you
happen to live in the LA area definitely
come see my live comedy show infinity
fan got all the jokes and bits that we
can't do here at new rockstars a super
depressed Batman will be in it along
with our good friend Tommy Beck told you
mind show details to take it a bow in
the description below and subscribe to
this channel for all the DC updates and
trailer breakdowns for this Joaquin
Phoenix stroke a movie and hey if you
don't Pike it don't worry the studio's
like it does another one's planned
thanks for watching